thank you
[Music]
let's wait did you do it do it for
another episode of just kidding news
today we have
Ryan as the whole okay
[Applause]
we'll introduce everybody
this is Nick the ear why you look like a
squirrel I'm a squirrel
Anthony the nose okay okay
wow good guys
[Laughter]
like those were jokes this what was that
I think your nails was great
with the nose anything else to say
that's all yeah I don't have anything
yeah that means the one for the first it
should be Anthony the hair dude look at
his hair it's really good hair you're
gonna backing them up but I'm just
saying that happened I'm not insecure
your hair is great
it's a great hair your hair overpowers
everything Ryan the host Nick the ear
so uh no article right now we're off the
Record um
I thought this would be a really cool uh
thing to talk about it might really help
somebody but um
we've all done different things in our
lives we've we've been around quite a
bit that we've had different Ventures
and and attempted several different
projects not all of them work out
um how do you stay positive when
something you're doing is failing
I'll go first uh you [ __ ] learn from
your mistake and you move on so you move
on that's the simple answer from the
from the thing you're doing you quit
doing it sounds easier it sounds easy
but it's actually not because one the
thing that mostly holds you back is your
pride your ego from your previous
identity from whatever that is because
it's like true look if you use the fans
don't need fortune cookie answers they
want to know real [ __ ] what failed and
what are you talking about dude I'll
tell you what the meat so that's true
because that's just sounds like every
other [ __ ] answer that you get on
like a meme on an Instagram
inspirational page
that's the fast answer I'm gonna explain
it okay okay explain it to you so garage
sales all right let's say
[ __ ] so one of the main things is I feel
like my dance career right A lot of
people don't see that but to me I feel
like I failed in my dance career but
then that was the old me like a few
years ago but you want ABDC what are you
talking about that was the end of it
right some of us went on the show and
lost can yeah no but here's something
grateful no here's the thing though like
even if you win and you have this
successful uh career and then it stops
it makes you feel like you're a failure
okay because it's like how come I'm not
getting any more shows or how come uh my
manager [ __ ] stole money from me and
now we have to get a new manager and all
this [ __ ] starts happening you're like
did my business just fail and then you
start questioning yourself so that's
when I was like okay so if this makes me
a failure what do I do now and why does
it make me a failure right but then when
you you won't know that until you go
through like whatever and then you
realize like it's you're not failing if
you keep going because then you can just
keep building right yeah
yeah I would like to apologize for my
earlier comments
that was very real
that's really cool of you to kind of
request that statement I'm just saying
man that's so funny no because that
that's like kind of the thing was I
realized that like why am I basing my
identity and my career just on Dancing
you know because like if if I didn't do
this anymore as a dancer and then people
could be like oh like your your career
is not nothing anymore because you don't
do it anymore but it's like because you
know how like some celebrities they have
their Golden Era and then it just ends
and it's like oh they're nobody they're
not relevant anymore so that's what was
going on in my head it's like are we
relevant are we not relevant but then at
the same time it's just kind of me
beating myself up and making myself
think that but then once I let go of
that and I let go of my previous
identity and just kind of let it die
then it allowed me to kind of feel like
oh shoot like in it was never really
there it's just something that you make
up in your head yeah yes follow-up
question do you still want to dance for
your career dude I'm still dancing he
just dances yeah where he goes so what I
what I uh realized was like I was never
even in control of my career in the
first place because at that time it was
just the opportunities that were just
coming and for me all I did was just
dance and take these opportunities and
ride that wave exactly because even
though uh there's not as much
opportunities now it's not my fault so I
didn't fail it's just how things are
right now because I still practice I
still do everything I do to like
maintain my talent and everything but
the thing is if there's no opportunities
here it's either I'm not looking for
them but or also it's just not the right
time well you're not creating it either
but but also you have a business now so
you're not really yeah but also um I
realized that I don't want to be stuck
to just one thing because to me like I
think change is growth and if you're not
constantly Reinventing yourself or
changing something you you're gonna feel
that same feeling of like oh no my
career is not where it used to be then
how can I make it better and you're
chasing that right but the moment you
start chasing it that's when I feel like
it's you're setting yourself up for like
the crash but it's such a fine life
because sometimes you're like uh if I
don't chase it then I'm not doing my I'm
not working hard enough or creating
opportunities it says you though but
then the that's only see the thing is
even though you chase it and if it
doesn't come it's like it was never
yours yeah exactly but yeah that's
actually what's the question again
uh how do you manage when you how do you
stay positive while you're failing
for Joe
okay okay so it doesn't always have to
be entire projects like maybe it's we
take it more the individual level how do
you stay positive when you're bombing on
a set
sorry
I I don't look at that you're like
you're like you know let's not talk so
let's get specific when you're bombing
I never bomb
I'm I'm fighting all of them no I think
standing goes
you always but I feel like that's what
everything like everybody like fails
like it and everybody you have to bomb
and you have to
yeah but then I who who said it first is
like they're like it's how you take it
like you're like earlier when people
said God damn your ears remember yeah
no I'm just saying look I'm just Anthony
said that Ryan was the one that said you
were bombing dude not me I know
[Laughter]
sorry what were you saying
I love you
I I never
um
thought of so like when when people say
that stuff like how do you stay positive
or whatever right I think like
it can be easily misunderstood as
suppressing your issues and stress and
keeping a smile right like and then so
for me
I'm more impulsive so like if I'm pissed
I'm pissed if I'm if I'm feeling it I'm
feeling it but I think what the key is
is how do you get back up and try again
when you've been slapped in the face a
thousand times and so you don't have to
stay happy because I mean naturally who
does feel happy when shit's going down
but I think the the strength in it all
is to remember what you're in it for the
first place and then get back and go
again and I think that becomes easier to
do once you've built the confidence in
achieving things so I think there's
different stages in someone who goes out
and challenges themselves to pursue
something the first stage is like hey I
might be doing something that that isn't
safe or traditional like like maybe I'll
go pursue my own passion or whatever and
then the first stage is can I even
support myself doing this right and then
you go and then you might get pushback
from family members you might get people
ridiculing you like you'll never ever be
a dancer or whatever the [ __ ] right
don't say it's like a [ __ ] movie
right that sounds like the choreographer
talking yeah and then and then you get
to that Scott what it takes you get to
that stage and then you you're you're
actually paying the bills now and and
whether it's your own business or
something that you kind of doubted
yourself in and you're proving to
yourself that oh cool I could put my
mind to something and I can achieve it
then the next stage is well how do I be
remarkable or different or like how do I
be a legend or how do I do something
like you want to grow within what you do
right and then you might even get burnt
out because like 15 years of doing
something you might be like I'm kind of
bored of the same space the same people
maybe I want some other stimulation
maybe I'll do another sport or something
different and I think it's like this
constant pursuit of like this is I'm
curious about this but I do think
there's a breakthrough where you no
longer question can I do this am I good
enough you just know so that anything
you put your mind to you just keep
trying and it's just time that's all it
is practice and time and getting better
over and over and over and over and then
it's just that repetition where you
become better at something do you have
any examples from your life where you do
this I think right now so like um during
covid you know the only thing I had
going for myself was JK news right and
that was my highlight it's like it was
really fun but we were I used to do JK
seven days a week but kovid was like I'm
only seeing you guys every two weeks and
then we shut down a lot of channels
the fun part was it was the first time
in many many years where I had total
freedom like I wasn't in a relationship
I could do whatever I want I could
travel the world if I wanted to I'm
calling my homies up and we're like
snowboarding every [ __ ] day till our
legs are dead and then so that was
really fun because I was like this is
what what it's like to be retired
and then I did it for a year and I
realized no matter what something felt
empty like like you can't just Chase
desires and fun like after a while you
go to your favorite restaurants every
single [ __ ] day then it gets to the
point of like
it's not it's normal so then it's like
it's like you can't chase feelings right
of of what do you call it like
stimulation then you go I need something
that I can fight against I need
something and one of the best things
that actually happened to me was losing
over like seven figures and wiping out
almost all of the money I had
because then it brought me back to the
space of like I have nothing well I had
a little bit but I had just enough to
invest back into jumbi in Hawaii and now
this became my fight and that became
like I have to make this work because if
I had 1.5 mil in my bank account I would
have not taken it seriously and I told
my partners this too like that's
actually a good thing that happened to
this because I would have just paid a
bunch of people as much as I could to
solve and just keep it running and I
wouldn't care if it made money but then
but then because that happened to me and
I kind of hit rock bottom not really but
I was just enough so it was just enough
to where I could pay for it it was just
enough to where I could pay my bills but
it was enough to make me afraid like I
lost everything bro that's crazy yeah
yeah and then when I was in Hawaii like
I'm just like now I'm driven now I'm
like this has to work if this doesn't
[ __ ] work I fail all my partners I
fail every everything and then and then
I felt alive and happy and it was the
weirdest feeling because it's like I had
more Bank in my in my bank last year but
I wasn't this happy struggling and
fighting to make it work yeah you know
that's why I think failure is an
illusion that we create for ourselves
but I think that it's disguised as
failure but we're really what it is is
like life setting a fire under you to
just say hey go now or else do something
yeah yeah that's what it really is but
you wouldn't have that perspective if
you didn't have a lot and then lose it
and then if you just was struggling the
whole time you wouldn't feel the way the
the gratefulness that you feel unless
you get that perspective of either I
mean you shave yourself I think like um
I thought I wanted the passive income
and retired life I thought I wanted that
and I dreamed about it and then when I
actually had it it's true what people
say like like that stuff is not
everything you ask actually lose a sense
of motivation and purpose yeah so then
so then getting to that point this point
right now is I'm in a much more happier
place even though I'm more stressed and
then like they're like are you okay like
my family members are just like dude I
know you lost a lot a lot I'm like I'm
actually way happier and and the best
way I can explain it is like you know
when you play a game or sports right
like it gets intense because you're
really in it so you could get angry
there's a lot of emotions but at the end
of the day it's stressful but you love
it and then you end the game and then
you feel the relax like relief like that
was a great [ __ ] game I might have
lost I might have won but the game was
sick and I felt like alive the journey
man that's that's really what it feels
like you wouldn't have that if you had
so much yeah yeah I think I think that
was
the key is experiencing the retirement
phase and then realizing it's not for me
and that's why I see why people they
actually die after retirement or they
get into depression after the retirement
like you lose your purpose yeah
that's deep Bro yeah so then the idea of
failure to me I think it's changed is um
definition because I definitely do
believe the word failure I was afraid of
fail like when I was doing JK and then
like I I quit college or I mean I
finished college and I was like I'm not
gonna do the regular nine to five I'm
gonna do YouTube I was afraid of failing
I was afraid of like I'm not gonna make
enough money doing this yeah and then
every year went by and I'm paying the
bills and then and then it becomes
abundant you become successful enough to
where you can pay for a team and
everything
and then you're afraid to fail like and
not being able to pay your team and it's
always there but the definition of
failure changes because someone might
see that you're successful but you might
think you're not you're failing yeah
but I don't know if now I see failure
the same way as I did before like I'm
not afraid to fail in the same way
anymore yeah
that was really good that was very good
yeah anybody else no I kind of roll out
after that
I feel like you tied that up on a nice
little bow and you know let's go back to
your bombing though
but I I don't know you not kill yourself
it must be so embarrassing up there
but you guys are all self-employed and
like entertainers or entrepreneurs in
your own right like you know what I'm
talking about when it comes to those
stages right and in the beginning
everyone has that fear of can I do it
yeah and it can I pay for like my life
doing what I want to or I never thought
I'd be able to pay
my bills doing what I do just like
training people or like yeah being a
coach what's up is it not good it can
it's like really stressful sometimes no
his bills are just that low yeah I just
I live in my white pace for everything
I'm not but like you know you you always
question like can I do this is this a
real job people always tell you like oh
you might like how do you survive how do
you pay for things and there's times
where it's like real slow and like with
clients and people are out of town like
this is like slow seasons and you're
just like [ __ ] how am I gonna pay for
this and you have that anxiety but like
sometimes you need
you're back against the wall for you to
actually push yourself to try to do
something different right that growth
that you're looking for because
otherwise if there's not a fire under
your ass then what the [ __ ] else are you
going to do sometimes you get really
comfortable I think that's like it's
really easy to do that and sometimes um
over the years of doing this for so long
there's been times where I'll kind of
like coast and be like oh yeah things
are going good you know I have clients
I'm booked up a lot and then when the
slow season hits you're like oh [ __ ] oh
man like I can't do this anymore I need
to make sure that you're always kind of
pushing forward and trying to like
add more things to your business or
trying to find a new way to gain
leverage in in what you're doing because
otherwise like that sense of security
like you you always feel like you need
it in a lot of ways
but it's it's I think it's you need to
leverage it by trying to find new ways
to improve either your business and
finding that Leading Edge because
otherwise you kind of get stale and you
get complacent and sometimes it does
take like covid to [ __ ] slap you in
the face and realize like oh yeah your
job could be taken away from you like
that and then you have no [ __ ] living
like for so long I never thought I'd be
able to train people online or like
coach people or or like understand how
to like for for so long I was always in
a gym and I was like this is my safety
net I'm totally cool seeing clients all
day whatever and then once that was
taken away from me I realized like what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do and I was
spanking dude I was freaking the [ __ ]
out I was like I don't know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna live in a [ __ ] box
and then it forced me to be like okay
there's a whole nother thing like the
internet that can help you like
you know build your business or or
leverage something else for yourself and
bolster like a little bit more support
and if it wasn't for that I would have
never done that because so many people
like Joe would be like you should coach
people online and I was like no dude
and like and part of it is ego right
because you feel like you you know
everything you feel like and these guys
have had so many conversations with me
and I'm like no I think I'm gonna do it
this way and I'm like oh what a [ __ ]
idiot it's also Comfort yeah it's
comfort you want to build your business
in the way you want to build it yeah
yeah and it's it's an experience and
sometimes you need to get humbled by
everything and you realize that like
once you pull back a little bit it's so
much of the reason why you don't do
things is your own ego and like what Ken
said like you think you know everything
you think you you've done it all but in
reality you don't know [ __ ] [ __ ]
about nothing dude yeah what does Ruth
say in uh Ozarks you don't know [ __ ]
about [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] about [ __ ]
Alice too here's another thing that
people don't really talk about is like
if you decide to quit your coaching or
you decide to quit Dancing you decide to
quit it's like you're not really
quitting it's all good it's a pivot
[ __ ] fine yeah it doesn't matter but
if you like something then yeah if you
like oh I like this thing then you could
give up because I think about that with
comedy all the time but if it doesn't
work out and like let's say you're
absolutely [ __ ] no income from this
nothing and you decide you know what I'm
just gonna [ __ ] be a lawyer or some
[ __ ] dude nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
like except for you you're the only one
that punishes your softly and that's
where you fail right but then it's like
why do we have to believe that you're
holding yourself back yeah but what if
you don't have another thing that you
like or like want to do
then then and then you're like well I'm
failing at this then I'm just I try
harder then the semis try harder yeah
you just might not know that you like to
do something else right that's that's
true too like he might say like you know
the thing that's stopping me from trying
online stuff is like my ego but there's
like a other side to that same you know
sword where it's like the thing that's
allowing you to go and try something
else is support from your friends like I
say this all the time like when you to
answer that question when it's like how
do you say positive during failure I've
said this before on this channel I'll
say it again to me it always comes down
to my support system and my friends and
my peers because if you don't have
friends if you don't have friends we'll
Circle back
but no that's that's the real deal like
any time and I've this probably happened
to me twice in my life where I've gotten
to like a serious Funk like something
just I just couldn't you know it was
just a lot right here yeah the thing
that got me out of that wasn't
necessarily the variables of my life and
my circumstances that was my perspective
on them it was my people around me right
at the lowest lowest point I ever had I
literally had to rationale with myself
and be like
all right who is my homie who's willing
to kick with me and am I looking I'm
looking at those people like these are
great human beings so like if they're
good people I have to be okay at least
and that would help me you know what I
mean or when they're telling me hey try
this try that that stuff and being able
to rely on the support of people that I
trust that maybe I value their opinion
especially in the time of my own
darkness of vision like that's the kind
of stuff that gets me going I don't talk
about this much or definitely not as
much as Joe but I was in that same boat
I also have my hands on over a million
dollars this past year and I lost it as
well yeah
we all got invested into the same [ __ ]
yeah it's so funny to make fun of my
failures huh
I wasn't trying I thought that's a good
joke Jason wanted to say orgies
I'm sorry that's the theme of the day I
didn't think about your failures
yeah but no like seriously it's like
going from that I had really really good
friends around me at that time that I
like really like they helped me cope and
I will never share like the depths of
how like far into my failure I felt but
if I didn't have very very close people
at that time supporting me 100 like that
[ __ ] would have been way harder to deal
with if I didn't have even homies in
this group that were calling just like
yo are you are you good yeah that would
have [ __ ] I I probably would have
been in way more Darkness so having a
support system having a group of people
that can think clearer than you when
you're in times of Darkness I think is
super super and we all bounce back
together I think we all the shared
experience made it made the blow a
little bit less bad I think totally
because we all had each other that were
like we lost a lot of our almost all of
our fortunes like with nothing left in
our bank account that was pretty [ __ ]
hard that's crazy and mentally too when
you're there especially in this part of
the adult life I remember thinking crazy
thoughts I was like dude I'm gonna
retire dancing you know what I mean like
you put yourself in a totally different
lifestyle mindset
you know what I'm saying and then
something very drastic happens as you
quote unquote out of your control and
suddenly you have to like switch all
these wires again you wanna you were in
the same boat sorry oh [ __ ] yeah but you
know like again like the very very first
thing that happened after that after
like in your mind nothing but like
Despair and loss is you realize nothing
in your life is really that different
than before you even had that great it's
all in the head yeah it's like every
reason an account it's all in the head
the same it's still right there but then
also too for your guys situation like
you could choose and I think sometimes
people get wrapped up in this where they
I don't say like choosing to be a victim
about certain things is just not helpful
for anybody right like you could sit
there and be like [ __ ] I lost it all and
like that could be what your world is
but sometimes like you said like
pivoting to other things and looking to
the other direction of like my support
and understanding that like oh yeah
pulling back the lens a little bit and
understanding that your life isn't that
different from what you thought you had
before so sometimes it's it's a matter
of just reframing and just realizing
that okay I lost that it is what it is
let's just move forward in simple like
that mental shift of just like all right
what's next that's the only thing you
can do too two things one I just want to
say that real quick that it's so cool
that to have everybody here that uh was
in a [ __ ] up situation and then came
back and then are able to share that's
so nice yeah and then because you guys
are okay with uh you know yourself a
little bit more and you also because
that's why I feel like you all have
empathy that that's so nice because not
every group has that that's one and uh
two I forgot number two after
some multiples but not everybody come
out of it oh that's my number two oh
okay yeah
wavelength my boy that's so nice but I
do think like what everyone has gone
through to get to that uh point of
confidence right like going through
multiple what other people will say
failures I would just say challenges of
proving to yourself you can do something
um that gets you ready for that mental
endurance of risk and loss so like it's
it's it has to happen over increments of
time like the more you separate from
doing what you're told to do and more
you go into doing what you tell yourself
to do yeah you start to build up a
different view of the world and now
instead of being a reaction to what
happens to whatever's going on in the
world you're no longer a victim now
you're in control of your destiny and
then you no longer question can I do
this now it's just I'm gonna do it and
spend time toward doing it and then when
you're there you forget
that time when you used to be afraid of
doing something even like someone who's
like hey I I'm I'm gonna try dancing you
probably might see it in your students
or whatever like someone's afraid to
even try working out or try because
their mind is like I don't think I'm
capable of doing it and we're like
you're so stupid all you got to do is
practice everyone's capable yeah but
then that's the stage that you forget
that you're in and people could stay
there for the rest of the [ __ ] life
it's a really big mental shift and it
reminds me of this analogy that this
monk made where it's like if you're
drowning in the river that those are
your problems right you're drowning in a
river but if you can imagine yourself
watching the river then you're out of it
it's like stepping away and changing
your perspective it's like most people
don't realize they're even in that River
it's like but if you step away from it
and you look at it as a river it's like
oh [ __ ] I'm not in it anymore you know
so it's like for you the whole crash and
everything it's like but you got to
remember it's like you're still here you
still got people you still got yeah
you've still got you and and you can
build build it back so you say people
love me and the same people hate me
nothing changed yeah it's really hard to
see it though exactly that's why you got
to use analogies but also don't you
think you just figure it out you'll
figure it out in time it's just not yeah
but in time so yeah this was a crazy
some people aren't patient when uh when
crypto and Luna and stuff like that
crashed and we like lost all it's coming
back really really short period of time
there were people you remember this
there were people that were afraid of
committing suicide they're just coughing
themselves yeah I remember like in a
short in that week there was like over
eight people that like straight up
committed suicide but my personal
journey I also remember like like
friends calling me who knew I was part
of it and we're like yo like I heard
like the stuff's going down like are you
okay and then I remember being like
oh yeah I'm I'm fine but then thinking
to myself like
you for calling me that's yeah holy [ __ ]
that's love yeah I think yeah I think
I'm good yeah let me check myself but
because you asked me you know and it's
like you you end up realizing that the
most valuable things you know what I'm
saying like are often times like still
right there if you just happen to pay
attention to that versus the thing that
you're going through
[Music]
foreign